les confiseries local des grands fils
vie locale comme quoi la bonne journée
alors là j'en ai réalisé c'est parti on
vous écoute d'un beau job connaissez
vous la martinique sur le bout des
doigts ses écrivains ses rivières
ces variétés de mangues ou d'oiseaux son
histoire ses quartiers historienne
sabine andriveau mythe on s'est amusé à
élaborer ses cartes 200 thèmes
différents qui font appel à notre
culture locale ce jeu qui destiné donc à
partir de 10-12 ans aux mêmes 1 oppose
des équipes des équipes qui ont une
minute trente pour faire donc des
propositions par rapport une thématique
qui ressort alors on est vraiment les
thèmes sont divers et variés ya de
thuyas la faune la flore les
personnalités la culture la chanson les
comédiens de tous et ça nous permet
aussi d'avancer sur le plateau de jeu et
l'équipe qui arrive la première donc au
morne-rouge un qui est le point le plus
élevé va gagner la partie
le jeu est sorti en juin en librairie et
certains sites touristiques
visiblement il anime bien les rencontres
entre amis qui pour une fois ont un jeu
pays mettant en avant la richesse du
patrimoine local
ouais découvrir qu'on avait les jambes
comme les doigts les douceurs tout ça
avec l'attentât n'avait vraiment brillé
comme ça qu'on faisait ça risque de
lasser pratiquement plus qu'est ce qui
explique que les gens accrochent comme
ça à ce jeu c'est surtout ce sont des
choses qu'on connaît et c'est un jeu qui
a
générationnel au stadio que les jeunes
ils peuvent y jouer parce qu'il ya des
termes assez content pour qu'ils parlent
de carnaval etc et avait été en plus
anciens comme les anciens cinémas mais
d'avant plus puisque bon je pense que
beaucoup de repères de personnes âgées
et des jeunes l'élite de connaître ceux
qui assurent la mort en s'amusant
oui on salue aussi bien sûr on a
l'impression que vous visez bien oui oui
sabine andriveau milthon à d'autres
cartes dans sa manche avec un jeu de
l'oie rebaptisé magny cours où un jeu de
l'échelle du mahb ou ya autant de
créations testé au préalable avec 16
élèves du lpa du robert les créations
familiale qui pour l'instant
s'autofinance le mois prochain un
coffret de quatre jeu sera édité à 1000
exemplaires